[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he was on the broadcast
last night with brian griese and steve
levy he's lewis riddick who was kind
enough to join us on the program
uh lewis let me start with this question
thanks for joining us was this a good
night for the cleveland browns
yes it was it was and i know you know i
said and i said last night dan that
there's no consolation prizes in the nfl
you know there's no moral victories but
i think
for this football team and for the city
given the fact that this is a team that
had beaten them eight out of the past
11 games i believe it was or 8 of the
past 10 games something like that
and given the fact that the narrative
surrounding the browns is really not a
narrative i mean
it's the truth that they hadn't beaten
anybody good
they hadn't really stood up and really
given the quality teams
for saving the nfl real good games
outside of playing tennessee the way
they did the week before and beating
them
they needed to have a good performance
they needed to have a strong performance
they needed to show that they can
compete for
three three and a half hours however
long a game is going to take
and compete at a high level and play an
exciting brand of football for really
people to say that's not the same old
brown
and i think they accomplished that and
if you know for a play here for them not
that you know
if it wasn't for the fact that they went
up against the reigning mvp who quite
honestly put on like a
superman like performance last night
they wouldn't get that football game and
i think people i think people if you
really look at it you don't have any
kind of grudge against the cleveland
browns
and or aren't just predetermined to say
look browns are the browns and they're
not they're
they're not going to be relevant again
and you would you would make that kind
of objective assessment
but this is a different football team
and kevin stefanski has been going in
the right direction
assuming both make the playoffs who
would be the tougher out
wow um i would probably still say
the ravens will still be the tougher out
because of the fact that
lamar is just so different he's such a
difference maker and
when his you know if he if he's not able
to
really get it going through the air
whether it be because he's not on
or because the yvc recorder is letting
him down
in many respects like he did last night
for the better part of the game
until you know mark andrews and marquis
brown make some good big plays late
i still think that they have enough on
the offensive side to
give every team a scare because of lamar
because of how special he is just as an
athlete overall and i think the defense
you know they were down some players
last night particularly in the secondary
then they started to cost them
late in the game i think the defense is
one where
they'll be able to ratchet it up and
they will be able to make enough plays
enough game-changing plays in order to
keep them in it and give lamar
enough possessions to win a football
game in a single elimination type
scenario so
i'd give them the nod yeah i would too
because
lamar is one of the handful of players
has that it factor and i think
the ravens are going to get healthier
here over the next month
but if i'm cleveland's defense like what
did they want lamar
to do last night what were they trying
to get him to do because
i still don't know yeah that's that's a
great point
it's a great point what what happened
was you know with him
they they let him get every time every
time they played man-to-man coverage
against their second against their wide
receivers
and they didn't have good vision on
lamar
that's when they got themselves in
trouble when they played
zone coverage played with good vision on
him kept him contained so to speak in
the pocket
and were able to rally to him because
they had 11 eyes on him
because people were able to play with
good vision they were relatively
successful
so i think that that's what wound up
happening when they broke down he he
doesn't give you much margin for error
and he took advantage of them whenever
they turned their back on him so to
speak and i
i said that a couple different times
last night that any time he's making
them pay
every time they try to make him pay
um by playing tight man coverage against
him and seeing whether or not he could
throw the football against him because
he'll just say hey look
maybe i can't get the ball where i need
to get it to right now in the passing
game but what i can always do
is i can always take off and run and
just gasp you that way and he did that
last night and i
and i think he he does that against a
lot of people he does that against
the majority people he goes against
cleveland still has some work to do dan
there's no question about that they
still have some people some
work to do on the defensive side where
they'll need some more
reinforcements and they'll need to add
some guys this all season and remember
denzel ward wasn't playing
last night either so i mean there's
there's still some work to be done
but um that's lamar lamar has you you
will have you start looking at your
roster and going man what else do i need
are we not really good enough when he
makes you look like that
did you have an idea what was going on
in the locker room
hey we were you know what i i suspected
that
you know maybe it was you know the
players sometimes you know nature calls
sometimes things just happen to where
you have to do
what you need to do i wasn't sure i mean
i just knew this when the ravens kept
saying that he wasn't
that there was nothing wrong with him he
wasn't hurt he wasn't injured really
i thought you know what it could be a
wide range of things but i really didn't
have any idea
you know quite honestly when tracy sully
went to the football game and he was
throwing the ball with some good
effectiveness i was like man this could
be interesting maybe we're going to see
a coming out party for trace mc shortly
right here
and then and then next you know he slips
and you know his knee gets
caught up i'm going what the heck is
going on then you see lamar come running
back out i'm going
this is this is just not this is high
drama right it was actually pretty cool
how it all happened
i just hope trace mcsorley is okay i
haven't heard exactly what you know the
extent of his injury but
i mean lamar told us what he told us as
far as what happened in the locker room
they've never left i mean the way he won
that game for him
you know before i mean he didn't win it
but the way he set it up for him
what a heck of a story okay have you had
how does that work when you played
yeah and you have to go to the bathroom
yeah
so how does that work you know
there's i mean i'm sure you've heard
stories man about it i guess it depends
what kind of going in the bathroom
you're talking about
all right i mean if you you just have to
go number one so to speak i mean some
guys
then look man i play with guys who just
go in there i mean mark slayer used to
talk about all the time about guys who
would just go in their pants you know
right there on the sideline i mean
there was no there's no porta-potty or
anything like that on the sideline
um some guys just would take
take matters in their own hands and so
to speak
when it comes to something else
for me that never happened i mean that's
the weird thing in all my years of
football
and pop warner all the way to the pros i
don't think in a game
that ever happened to me where i and i
don't remember there being a situation
where
it became an issue for someone else you
know it was usually something that
people took care of at halftime or
whatever
but i remember rodney harrison saying
what happened to me rodney harrison said
that you just sit on the bench put a
towel underneath you
i have never seen somebody do that i i'm
telling you i've never said that
i've never seen that but that would that
would be wild i would have known if that
would happen believe me man
i would have known but that this never
came up he's louis riddick espn monday
night football analyst former pro scout
director of pro personnel
and uh former nfl defensive back do you
hold any grudges
with anybody that you played against was
there somebody that hit you
said something like it'll never go away
uh
no no i don't not not while we were
playing no because you know
but now like you no no i mean
there's nobody really that that i would
say that i feel as though
you know i didn't even score with or or
something like that no
i don't and the reason why honestly is
because
i i know that you know that's just the
way football goes man
i mean sometimes you get them they get
you and
i think the reason why i felt i'm good
with that is because
as many times have i got whacked and
or hit or beat or whatever it is
i know i gave out my fair share and i'm
good with that and i i kind of like it i
kind of liked it like that i never felt
like anybody hit me dirty or anybody
tried to
injure me or anything like that so it
was
i was good with the give and take
did you ever hit somebody and feel sorry
uh yeah i i think i think i did you know
we were we were
when i was a rookie in atlanta in 92 in
the preseason we were playing against
cleveland
uh i'm playing for jerry glenville then
and
there's a wide receiver who caught a
slant route
now the interesting thing about that was
i was groggy in that game you know those
were these were back in the days before
you know there was like a real extensive
you know
checking on players who you know maybe
had had
concussions or what have you and you
know i i know i was i was not
right in that game and i wasn't quite
sure yeah i had a couple big hits on
kevin mac in the preseason and you
remember how big kevin mac was so i mean
every time you hit kevin mac he's going
to kind of knock your
screws just a little bit and i hit this
wide receiver
simply because i was standing in the
middle of the field didn't even know
what the defensive call was and i just
know the ball was thrown and i just
sprinted towards wide receiver and just
literally i mean just hit him with all i
had
and one of our defensive backs
i think his name was frankie smith was
hanging on him at the same time
and i knocked the wide receiver out i
mean he was out cold
and i believe he wound up having you
know he suffered some kind of injury to
his neck or back
and frankie smith who was hanging on him
in the corner who was covering at the
time
his finger got caught between me and the
wide receiver
and it just obliterated his finger and
i think that's the time where i felt man
not only did i injure the guy i injured
one of my own teammates and i wasn't
even quite sure what i was you know what
i was supposed to be doing at the time
so yeah some of those big hits like that
you feel bad afterwards
but i mean that's just the way the you
know that's the way the game was and
that's the way
we played it and that's the way i played
it and you didn't want to see guys get
hurt
but it definitely you know in the 90s
80s
you know it was a different type type of
game you know back then
especially when ken came to collisions
and high speed collisions in the
secondary
i mean they were a regular current you
know how that was well i tell this
audience all the time
if you saw a game from the sidelines
yeah
you would never let your kid play that
game
because no doubt it is just i can close
my eye i
i went to a giants game and i was on the
sidelines when lt was there and that
great defense
i closed my eyes because i wanted to
hear
a game for a couple plays holy smoke
show
it was it was scary louis
scary the sound the images
yeah the sound the collisions i and i
played with
when i was in cleveland and then when i
was in atlanta too in atlanta i played
with
scott case jeff donaldson jesse tuggle
scott casey jeff donaldson at safeties
were pound per pound two of the toughest
guy
guys who ever played in the nfl i saw
scott case
leave his feet and hit people and the
sound that you would hear
it was like like a bomb went off i
played with eric turner in cleveland
eric turner was easily in that category
of
the you know the late great don rogers
kenny easley ronnie lot dennis smith
those types of guys who were just
vicious
vicious hitters vicious and when i
played for the raiders at the
last year of my career i mean those were
i mean when i went out there every time
i was trying to hit people like
like george atkinson hit people like you
know love them or not i mean
jack tatum was probably the biggest
hitter of all time
and you're right when you're doing it
it's not that you don't you don't really
know how just how vicious it sounds but
when you see your teammates do it and or
if you're on the sideline you see
another defender do it you realize this
is not for the timid man
it's not for the timid at all oh
i'll leave you with this the number of
teams that you honestly think
can go to the super bowl in the afc and
the nfc
let's start with the afc that you truly
believe they could play
they could represent their conference in
the super bowl
yeah well you know kansas city can and
they probably will you know buffalo
right now buffalo's on a mission
and and i think they are going to be
they're going to give kansas city all
they want in a rematch type scenario
we know kansas city ran ran over them
pretty hard earlier in the season
i think those
those two in the afc are probably the
ones who you legitimately
legitimately say you know in all
different types of environment scenarios
those two teams can travel and they can
play you know they can play you
however i think the cults are sneaky
because chris ballard is starting to
give him that kind of you know
he's kind of building them in that kind
of image are you sold on phillip rivers
no and i think you know i think in the
end when you assess
them i mean i'm sold on philip rivers as
a as a quality court i mean he's done
great things in his career i just don't
know if he has enough gas in the tank
to deal with a team like buffalo and
josh allen like kansas city and
patrick mahomes those guys are special
those guys can make the difference phil
can't be the difference anymore yeah
and i think that's the difference all
right uh nfc
how many teams legitimately can go to
the super bowl
yeah you know in a one-off type of
scenario i mean i think
i think you probably have to count out
the teams in the nfc east
only because you know i just don't know
if they're ready yet although
you know teams like washington and and
even the giants i mean they're showing a
lot of grit here late in the season i
just don't know if they're
if they're ready to contend with the
packers because you know
aaron is just that special on him him
and matt on the floor have it going on
so that's one of them
you know the saints are going to be
there despite the egg they basically
laid against philadelphia last week you
know they're going to be there because
they can do it all
offensively and defensively especially
when drew's healthy
tampa i'm not so sure man anymore
about tampa i just don't know i mean
bruce says he can that they can do
whatever the hell they want quote
unquote as far as their
identity offensively i'm just not so
sure but they gotta win
three games on the road though lewis
they're not going to have home field
advantage
exactly but you know i mean a lot of
people in the nfl believe home field
advantage doesn't mean anything
and i guess it depends where they have
to go especially in this
in this pandemic here i guess it depends
where they have to go if they have to go
somewhere cold weather then maybe that's
the equalizer but i don't think home
feels the same as it is i really don't
i really don't but we'll we'll see with
them seattle and then
seattle if their defense can continue to
come on
yeah and the right but the rams too
though the rams to me
that's right there's a lot more in the
nfc they're silent
that's right the ram the rams are a down
and dirty type team
great defense brandon staley is a great
young coach
up and coming coach to be a head coach
very soon and on the offensive side
when sean is in that rhythm and jared
goff is in that rhythm with him
they will run the ball down your throat
with those backs that they have
and then they'll guess you with that
play action passing game i i they are
sneaky
actually they're not sneaky anymore
people know that sean mcveigh is a good
coach and they know that they have a
solid football team
so yeah there's a lot more possibilities
in the nfc
it'll be the steelers at the bengals
next monday night louis thanks for
joining us we appreciate your time
absolutely dan always love coming on
thank you that's lewis riddick
a former defensive back former scout
director of
pro personnel